however that's not enough
right however many are being indicted
and thrown in jail it's not even close
to the
hundreds of thousands of people we saw
taking to the streets looting
burning tearing things down
and at the same time we're being told
that we need to defund the police
so unfortunately people need to take
their own safety
into their own hands most people would
prefer not to do that
okay i i don't know a single gun owner
who wants to have to go out on his
property and start aiming at
roving bands of anarchists and
thugs and looters and possibly killers i
don't know anyone wants to do that what
we'd rather do
is live in nice safe neighborhoods
that's why wealthy people i know the
wealthier they get
the safer the neighborhood they move
into okay but when you're being told
that police departments are not going to
get backed up they've got to stand down
people are walking off the job they're
getting defunded
the law is not being enforced well
people have to take their own safety
into their own hands and that's what
happened
with the famous the now famous st louis
gun couple
you might have seen them to me this
should be the the new image in the
brooks brothers catalog is this man
walking out
in a pink polo shirt and white chinos
with his white
tennis shoes holding an ar-15 and his
wife holding a little i don't know a
little tiny guy like a little james bond
gun or something
i love these guys they're doing great
turns out they're democrats i still love
them it's okay don't worry about it
what happened hundreds of black lives
matter anarchists
trespassed on private property on their
way by the way to go bother the saint
louis mayor at the saint louis mayor's
home
as these black lives matter anarchists
were
marching through the private property
they destroyed some of that private
property somehow managed to destroy a
wrought iron gate
and uh and possibly some other stuff so
this couple walked out of their home
still on their own property
and they walked out with weapons
uh here is just a quick clip of
the the wife walking out with her james
bond gun
while the rioters threatened her life
and her property
you know off my lawn
listen old man you don't wanna [ __ ] with
me did you hear me i said get off my
lawn
now are you crazy go back in the house
yeah
i blow a hole in your face and then i go
in the house and i sleep like a baby
you can count on that we used to stack
like you
five feet high in korea use you for
sandbags
uh sorry sorry that i got confused for a
moment that was actually
clint eastwood in gran torino but a very
similar scene you saw
from this woman in saint louis walks out
with her gun didn't have great trigger
discipline i'm
sorry to say but who cares i mean that's
sort of missing the point when you argue
about how she's holding her gun and
whether it's safe or not you know what i
don't think is safe when roving bands of
anarchists are marching through private
property
i think actually when when that starts
to happen when the whole country starts
burning down and people are
shooting and looting and killing and
stealing then i don't think we need to
be necessarily so
neurotic about exactly how we're holding
the gun i think at that point you're
trying to protect your life
and your livelihood which is exactly
what happened
mark and patricia mccloskey are their
names
uh the way they describe it is a mob of
at least a hundred smashed through the
historic wrought iron gates of portland
place
destroying them rushed toward my home
where my family was having dinner
outside put us in fear of our lives of
course that's what happened
they're peaceful rioters of course
peaceful they peacefully destroyed
property they've been peacefully burning
down buildings and peacefully tearing
down statues
and peacefully killing people for the
last three weeks but they are peaceful
because the people wearing ties and
jackets on the mainstream media tell me
they're peaceful
so the city attorney for uh for the city
kimberly gardner
she's the circuit attorney rather uh was
very upset about this she said you're
not allowed to protect yourself
she said we must protect the right to
peacefully protest
you know like all those rioters were
doing and any attempt to chill it
through intimidation or the threat of
deadly force
will not be tolerated make no mistake we
will not tolerate the use of force
against those exercising their first
amendment rights
to steal stuff and threaten people's
lives and
we will use the full power of missouri
law to hold people accountable
this is it these are this the privileged
group is black lives matter and antifa
and all the other leftist riders they're
a privileged group they have the first
amendment right to kill you and steal
your property
but you a citizen a law-abiding citizen
do not have any rights first amendment
second amendment nothing
you've got to lay down and let these
rioters kill you all in the name of
social justice
that according to the circuit attorney
and at that point
the couple has pledged loyalty to black
lives matter
it turns out this couple actually is
probably democrats they've donated to
act blue many times
at first i thought they only pledged
fealty to blm just so they don't get
their livelihoods destroyed
and you know they're lawyers and
obviously they've got a pretty good life
going for them
uh but it looks like they actually might
be democrats i don't know if they're
democrats anymore they might have been
democrats for the last 20 years but
nothing like a band of anarchists to
wake you up to political
reality regardless of their political
views or they counted to blm or whatever
i give them credit for defending
themselves in the moment they are
completely in the right
these riders are wreaking havoc in
stealing property and killing people all
over the country
governments have defunded the police and
the only thing left to many americans
is self-defense if you
are not defending the st louis gun
couple
you just don't get it you just don't get
the political situation that we're in
you just don't get how it's all stacked
against you you think
i would assume that just as long as we
play by the left's rules and we don't
rock the boat too much
then we'll win eventually a victory for
us is just around the corner just one
more judge
just one more judge and we'll win right
if you think that you don't get it you
don't get the situation
[Music]
you